[MUSIC]
No more liking Ofunato
Maybe
let me talk
about how
to say it  I met you 5. I want you
to
repair my broken ship and take care of
me.At that time, I still didn't know that he was a ship.
I heard you weren't
there,
but I think things have changed since we met.
At
first,
they might have thought they were going to run away,
but in the end,
they fought alongside us to
respond to
Kagura's feelings.  I believe you too I believe in
the
way you say it
He's the one who understands when he speaks
I want to be able to smile and talk again Okay
let me turn the
[music] off [music]
okay I'll give
you guys time  Library 16,
Tokoro Cha
So, let's make a relationship right away.
How to leave Funato I don't think it will go down
What will you do then